I don't think that there's room in the
rap game for a sweet tea and a sweet tea
so in this case I think it's a hot sauce
it's an MC good lord
hey what's going on everybody this is
Sean Evans I'm backstage at the Kelly
Clarkson show and about to play a little
game called hot sauce or MC is it a hot
sauce or is it an MC first name is it a
hot sauce or an MC the Grim Reaper did
Grim Reaper that sounds sort of hot
sauce E but that's like very underground
MC I feel like the Grim Reaper plus like
if it was Reaper I'd think it as a hot
sauce but since its reefer I think it's
an MC the Grim Reaper is it an MC or is
it a hot sauce it is an MC ding ding
ding ding one for one hope you're
keeping score all right up next Midland
ghost Midland ghost I'm not sure I'm
this one again just using context clues
but I think that it's a hotsauce Midland
that does not sound like a rap name to
me it sounds like a hot sauce name so
I'm gonna go with hot sauce correct -
four - all right up next Bay s spicy or
be spicy I feel like if that was a hot
sauce name like this is one of those
that's put in here specifically to trip
me up you guys thought because I saw
spicy I'd say hot sauce but it looks
more like a name to me so I'm going MC
incorrect it's hot sauce I got cocky
showing my math there a Golden Girls
line of hot sauce I'll like be like the
Earth's but okay I get it up next weed
killer weed killer not my brain is
spaghetti now I don't know what to think
weed killer sounds like an MC but it
sounds like an MC but
in here because it's actually a hot
sauce that's where I went down with this
last one so I'm not gonna fall for it
again
weed killer is an MC it's a hot sauce
started off on fire now cooling off a
little bit
two four four you can stop keeping score
little Windex that's an MC bang bang
little Windex I think I've seen a video
on YouTube lil roadie or rowdy I'm gonna
go with MC incorrect hot sauce you're
good at stacking these cards you knew
what you were doing little roadie Rhode
Island hot sauce shoutout to little ro D
that's a good name now I don't know what
to think I'm about 50% over here trappy
Chainz as a dog named trap you is there
a rapper named trapping I'm gonna go
with there is a rapper named traffi that
would put me at four four seven if or
now I'm looking and I'm looking at your
face and I'm switching my answer I think
it's a hot sauce it is a hot sauce I can
see it in her face
but that counts I think I'm plus one now
sweet tea sweet tea well I know
so ET is an MC sweet tea sweet tea would
seem to infringe on that name a little
bit I don't think that there's room in
the rap game for a sweet tea and a so
weak tea
so in this case I think it's a hot sauce
it's an MC good lord
dirty dick is a hot sauce dirty dicks
it's one of my favorite hot sauce is in
fact this one I'm confident and though
it is a good rap name a dirty dick
that's a hot sausage
all right old Florida now this to me
sounds like a beer Oh God
pick up a six-pack will hold Florida but
it could be this is a coin flip to me
old Florida I'm gonna go with hot sauce
bang bang
Black Milk great hot sauce names great
MC name in this case though I think it's
an MC Bing day anybody keep its floor
and pen on a roll again masta Killa
that's an MC I know that I feel like
kids you got to end with a swish and
this is the last card so I feel like
there's a lot at stake you know you got
to make Killa kimchi now I know how
you've stacked this deck masta Killa
that's an MC you're not gonna put two
killers so this one kill like kimchi I
say as a hot sauce correct
so backstage at the Kelly Clarkson show
having a great time MC air hot sauce
there you have it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going